so when you were a young deaf girl what
kind of access to information and
technology did you have to be honest I
was closed off I spent my whole
childhood lost I would be sitting next
to my parents as they watched a movie or
TV they'd be laughing at the TV and I
would just be looking trying to guess
what was going on and if I needed to
call my parents I would have to walk up
to a stranger tap them on the shoulder
and hand them a note saying would you
mind calling my mother and having her
pick me up here then I just have to
stand next to this weird stranger and
watch them blabber on the phone and then
look at me like okay your mom's on her
way yeah well I mean it's a good thing
they were calling like our other
kidnapper buddy like hey I got this hot
deaf girl bring the van ha ha you know
you get used to it you just kind of
accept that that's your lot in life I
guess I'll just have limited access to
communication so did the Internet remove
some of those limitations absolutely the
Internet and Technology gave me freedom
I feel more intelligent more confident
and I feel better about myself and when
you were young and you wanted to like
call a friend how would you do that I
would actually have to ask my mom to
call my friend's mom and set up an
appointment for the two of us to hang
out and then we'd drive 30 miles or
something to go meet my friend right so
now you can finally just call her right
I could do that right now hi I can't
talk I'm on TV doing an interview with
Moshe
look look look here's my best friend so
then I decided you know what I'm going
to get a cochlear implant one of those
robotic ears and that really changed my
life you receive those videos of deaf
people turning on their cochlear
implants for the first time and
everybody gets all emotional like I
realized we never got a chance to do
that and I've always been kind of
disappointed do you think we could try
it okay okay now bake turn it on hey mom
oh your boy my boy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
thumbs-down sorry
yeah look I'm deaf and it still sounds
terrible you know I remember when I
first got a closed captioning device
like a subtitle machine and I would put
it on and sit with you and we would
watch Sesame Street together watching
the subtitles I had captioning and I
could finally understand what was going
on I missed what was happening when I
was a kid but I didn't have to miss it
when you and your brother were young
well thanks for coming mom I love you I
love you too now go seriously